how's it going guys matt here code tech
tutorial just wanted to give you the
yearly update and say happy holidays to
you all hope you're having a good one
and i just kind of want to let you know
the plans for the channel because i know
it seems like it's been a little up in
the air this last month or two
and well i don't really know exactly
what to say about that other than it is
what it is and yes there's been some
some stress
for me involved in me figuring out what
i want to do with my life and how to
handle things
and uh you know it's it's kind of the
kind of stuff that we all go through i
think but it's uh
it's kind of taken me by a little bit of
a surprise so i just want to get my plan
set in stone and kind of set the
expectation for this next upcoming year
for the people that follow my channel
and me
because i do really appreciate you guys
and it does mean a lot and sometimes i
feel like i'm not very good at
expressing that all right so
code yeah
getting into youtube was
tricky
i did not expect for things to go the
way they did i never even really
expected this channel to grow i don't
know really what i expected i was kind
of doing it blindly and just just
winging it and uh
you know i guess where there's a passion
you're gonna find an audience and
obviously have a passion for all this
code and tech stuff and
i think that's never going to go away so
i
predict i'll be doing it for the rest of
my life in any case but this next year
i want to start really doing what i set
out to do because when i started
programming the only reason i really
wanted to do it was well i got that two
reasons i was tired of other people's
buggy software so i just thought that
maybe i can contribute and do better and
also i really wanted to make my own
video game i've had a lot of ideas in
the past and i think it's time i'm sure
i've made a lot of little small games
and stuff but i don't really have
anything that i can
show off to like a big name company or
something like that
or anything on steam or you know
anything like that just a lot of little
demos and a lot of little samples
and
i think it's time for me to change that
and
yeah so i'm going to start working on
the the game extended stay that i
somewhat talked about in a previous
video
and i don't know exactly how it's going
to go but i intend to start putting out
stuff for it and start working towards
it in this next year
and this whole engine here my old
ancient archer engine which has moved
into the private space
that's what this is going to be built to
support so i'm going to build it on my
own engine and this engine is going to
be built to support the game i'm making
and i don't know where it's going to go
one of the reasons i decided to make
this the future iterations of this
engine private is because well
it's complicated but basically i don't
know where i'm going to take it
exactly and
until then i don't really feel like it's
a good idea to just kind of like
pull in different directions all the
time and not really know i don't know
how to explain it other than that and
also i guess you know one of the bigger
things is i'm gonna have
other libraries attached to it that are
to do with this game i'm gonna make and
obviously i don't want to release all
that source code and stuff before i even
release the game so i'm trying to keep
i'm trying to figure out what to keep
private and whatnot but it's a it's a
complicated thing now what i thought
about doing is just making like a public
version of this specifically for the
channel and when i work on it i can
maybe stream it on
youtube or something and we can also
take contributions from other people
that watch the channel and want to add
in their stuff because making a game
engine
once you've
kind of dove into the main stuff you can
recreate it up to where you are pretty
quickly it's making those
incremental advancements to next phases
it's hard but once you you have it you
kind of have it permanently at least
that's my take on the whole thing
or kind of what i've realized so i've
got definitely some big steps to make
i still need to finish a lot of
different things right now this is uh
the branch i'm on right now it's called
giant ecs rework
oh
so currently i'm
working in an ntt entity component
system but also i'm working on a few
other things too but uh you know as one
person you got to kind of try to pick a
road stay on it you finish it
and then go to the next road but also i
have like shadows halfway done and i
have
something else halfway done i can't
remember oh yeah i guess the animations
are probably a little more than halfway
done
and there's a lot of other little things
that are just like partially in here but
i don't have a good enough
implementation of it yet to really put
out there so
me working towards this game in the next
year is going to mean a lot of things
and
i can tell you what it
definitely does mean and what it
definitely doesn't mean but i don't have
an exact summary because i'm still
figuring things out as i go it does mean
that this uh
this engine isn't going away i'm going
to keep working on it it also means that
i'm going to keep making content but i
don't know how i'm going to make the
content i think i'm going gonna do a lot
a kind of a series of shorts about game
engines for when i
research
because sometimes i'll stay on the topic
for a day or two and i'll i'll heavily
research it and by the end of that i
sort of have this nice group of
knowledge i feel like i can just if i
can just put that in a little video for
you guys
i feel like it's something that i would
have loved to see when i was trying to
figure this stuff out originally it's
just some quick snippets
of uh like the core knowledge so i'm
going to try to create a little game
engine series of just little quick
snippets of core knowledge i already did
one of cameras that's kind of maybe a
sample
really long that one but i want to do
that for like a lot of different aspects
of game engine as i go because those are
videos i can throw together quickly and
not try to
distract too much a lot of the problems
i had in the past
was that i would make these giant
productions
of little things
like how to use c plus plus and visuals
studio or something like that like if
you know the knowledge you can just kind
of put it out there
but for me i felt like i had to make it
a big production and
that would make it a lot more watchable
and i think in part that's what helped
me grow but also that started to lead to
burnout
and i don't think it would have led to
burnout if i like secured finances to
get an editor but i that didn't happen
so i was doing the editing
you know just the whole nine yards it
was just too much and basically what
ended up happening last year that i
think really drove me to the point of
almost quitting
was that i found that i was spending a
lot more time stressing and worrying
about making these videos than actually
living my dream of just like
being a really good programmer and
putting out
actual software like i basically all the
the software basically took a backseat
and it was all about this
social thing of you youtube which
you might have figured out
by now that i don't really i don't
really get off on the whole social media
thing i don't particularly care how many
people follow me or don't follow me or
and stuff like that i'm i'm just not
that type of person it's and it's not to
say that i don't like it i mean it's
tricky for me to even get right in my
own head like
there's a there's a big part of me
that doesn't particularly care what
other people do i'm always just kind of
focused on my own thing
and that's it has its advantages but
that also has some downsides too
and i guess i could talk about that
briefly like the biggest downside of
this mentality is that
i heard a lot of people's feelings
basically because they get the
impression that i don't care about them
it's not that i don't care about
them as a person because i do
and i want them
you know i want people to be happy and
all that stuff and i want people to live
their dreams
it's just that i don't let other
people's actions affect me um i think
that's kind of what it comes down to for
the most part you know it's not 100 true
but in general once my mind is set on
something i don't really care what other
people say to me about that thing it's
like i'm going to do it no matter what
you say because i want to do it and i
always
think that other people think like that
too i always think that other people get
ideas and do what they want because they
want to do it but that doesn't seem to
be true for most other people and i
think you know now that i'm putting out
there on the internet people are
probably going to listen and be like
yeah i like that too but in the people
that surround me in my daily life
there's not many like that
most of them are
either
kind of in the rat race or
just trying to get through the day stuff
like that and
they care a lot about what other people
think of them and they have like high
anxiety and stuff
and i don't really have that i don't
have much anxiety
when i do have it i i can squash it real
quick
um just by the way i think i don't i
don't really
it's a weird thing to talk about but
you know this video is getting to be a
little bit long um
i don't even know if i've covered
everything i wanted to cover but mainly
i just kind of wanted to give you guys
an idea of
where i'm at in my plans going forward
i've just got so many like things on the
back burner that i don't know when i'll
get to them
you've seen my lists sometimes i post
them on patreon or here on the community
tab
or you can look at my playlist and see
which ones are incomplete there's
just it's basically a lot of stuff that
i would love to do
but to find the time is tricky like i
might be able to find the time to get
the first half of it done then when it
comes to editing and stuff
i'm in a different headspace or i'm
working on something else so i guess i'm
just saying i hope you'll stick with me
through this next year and uh i really
appreciate you guys
so yeah i always feel awkward asking for
people to like and sub but
supposedly you've got to say that or you
don't really want it
they say if you don't ask you don't
actually want it but i you know
and i do and i appreciate it and uh if
you want to go to extra mile there's a
joint button you can help
support the channel financially that way
too
but of course all your interaction means
a lot
and i'm going to try to be a little
better about comments i've kind of been
ignoring the vast majority of them
unless they're from some paid supporter
for the last couple months and i have my
reasons mainly that i was overwhelmed
and just
mentally was not in a space to get to
everybody
so yeah that's it hope you guys have a
good one peace out